John wick Chapter three is out and as of
this taping it is the highest rated film
in the series at 95% fret where the last
two installments at 87 and 89% certified
fresh' people are saying this make John
wick the best action franchise in cinema
history is this true well we're gonna
try to find out hi everyone I'm Mark
Ellis welcome to the after show this is
a spoiler heavy show so you've been
warned we have a fantastic panel here
today joining me on the couch is rod
tomatoes editor Alex veau Club we also
have live via the miracle that is Skype
she is a rotten tomato certified critic
and the host of Beyond The Trailer grace
Randolph is joining us grace can you
hear me okay I can hear you all the way
on the other coast it's just we live in
such a great time and also joining us on
the couch we have a very special guest
and that would be a man who has worked
on countless movies he's the stunt
coordinator for John wig 3 he's also
done franchises like the Bourne movies
he worked on spider-man 2 he is the one
the only mr. Scott Rogers nope so
excited to have you Scott before we get
into talking about the actual movie
you're the stunt coordinator on John
wick 3 and I think I kind of know what a
stunt coordinators in the title it's a
cool-looking title and so for this
particular movie can you give us a
glimpse as to what sort of things you
had responsibility for on set I mean
you're you're ultimately over seeing the
entire department so you know the things
as mundane is just getting contract
information to production so guys are
getting paid to hiring the right people
for the right job to take in each
sequence and breaking it down and
developing the technology and the you
know how you're going to shoot what
you're going to shoot make sure you have
the right people to do it it's a whole
lot of hats you're wearing for this
movie yeah I mean takes I'm ultimately
the the guy at the top but there takes a
whole lot of people to make all of that
happen well it's a lot of hard work that
went into making this movie me I just
got to shovel a lot of popcorn in my
face and enjoy the heck out of John wick
3 because I clearly consider this movie
fresh it's arguably the best in the
franchise but grace I want to toss it to
you right off the bat do you consider
John wick
to be a fresh movie oh it's the freshest
tomato possible not a bruise on it it's
the finest one in the bush we'll have
about you Alex are you going fresh as
well Oh Parabellum is fresh yeah and
Scott I mean we have a bunch of fresh is
here in the studio and now as we get
into actually talking about this film
Keanu Reeves is the headliner of John
wick II plays John wick but I think you
walk out of this movie and you say the
star of the movie we're all of the fight
scene so I'm gonna get to all of the
cool fight sequences that we got to
witness some of them just keep going and
going and going you can't imagine that
there's any more left in the tank and
just when you think it's done there's
more fight scenes the one in particular
that everyone was buzzing about when I
left my theater Scott was the knife
fights it was so intricate that one
knife sequence that just kept on giving
us more goodness talk about the fight
scene and how that might be the best one
in the series well I mean so I mean
everybody knows Chad and Chad's you know
comes from a stunt world and a fight
background he was a professional fighter
and Chad's the Wes key dish Don so I had
a previous Canterbury's movie with the
matrix oh yeah yeah double Keanu Reeves
for a number of years they're good
friends so I think that knife fight is
something he's had brewing for a long
time and Jonathan you subió who is the
fight choreographer and his entire team
that are just hands down the they're the
best in the business
I mean how queer Lee shows in that knife
fight because Gracie watch that knife
fight and I don't know about you that
was my favorite fight in the entire
movie is up there it's like it's real
Sophie's Choice I have to say like how
many if you can disclose how many of the
knives are real cuz there's this one
part of the fight where Keano is just
like wailing on this guy with knife
after knife and I'm like where are they
coming from it's almost like a magic
trick well I'll tell you that all the
ones that went into the body weren't
real
if someone got stabbed that wasn't real
my whole audience i didn't look away
from the screen for the first like 30
minutes of the movie because i want to
miss anything except for when it went
into the eye the knife went into the I
have a that set the stage for the whole
movie I mean you literally are like
alright we're in for that kind of ride
here we go it's like seeing the pencil
trick again yeah it's slower and more
painful yeah which is better you can't
do this pencil trick again yeah Alex
what was your reaction to watching the
knife fight I think the knife fight is
probably up there in John Wick's series
it's it kind of represents the best of
John wick it's kinda like if you look at
the fight with common in part two when
he's on the subway spatially it's the
same thing it's in a hallway it's in a
subway the audience knows where the
entrance and the exits are so you kind
of put the camera anywhere in that fight
and you orient the audience pretty much
right away
so it's clear it has long takes it has
knives
it has gunplay and then had that
cathartic moment where John wick just
throw that ax and there's like yes
beautiful well you have to you've gotta
give Chad a lot of credit for you know
and what we try to do much like in a
movie which you do in an individual
scene you try to bring it up and then
kind of give it a moment and then rise
and deal and create an entire arc within
that sequence and that's what you know
there's a little bit of levity and then
there's some intensity and so it it
takes you on this little three to four
minute maybe five minute or 10 minute
however long it's there's a funny moment
where they realize they're in a hallway
full of knives well yeah we couldn't do
something else with this here you know
that's like the humor is really
appreciated in the movie yeah it really
makes the scene so amazing it's not just
any weapons they're kind of like in a
museum
yeah it's mandatory beginning with the
gun that he has to like assemble like
you know different parts and you know
they're in glass cases I mean that's
really cool that element like these
antique knives it's like it's like
you're in Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory just replaced the chocolate with
knives another one of my
favorite fights yeah a little bit more
deadly is the the motorcycle sequence
because I believe it was inspired by the
villainous which is a South Korean
action film it grates when you saw the
motorcycle fight
can you just believe that your eyeballs
are witnessing something that's such a
cool fight sequence at such high speeds
well it's so cool and I think that
there's a lot of showmanship that you
and your team did you know when they all
draw the samurai swords at once you know
like okay here we go and I got the other
great thing about a number of the fights
including this one is that you know in a
lot of movies you know like they
wouldn't you know why are they going one
at a time you know but here Keanu was
fighting multiple people on a motorcycle
at the same time in a believable way
yeah I mean we went to great lengths to
make sure people weren't just you know
attackers weren't coming in because it
wasn't time you know they were we were
trying to block their route with another
motorcycle and you know make have it
make sense not just be you know random
for no reason yeah grace I love you
brought up that point because so many
times Alex you're watching an action
movie and it's like everybody's just
kind of hanging around to check in to
the ballgame
it's like oh you're trying to get this
right that's what I felt watching John
wick through guys like no I'll take him
myself
a motorcycle scene because once you
knock a guy down he's out he's not
coming back up he's like two miles
behind you yeah you know so yeah and
other if I've seen you knock a guy down
you might do ya think about he's gonna
get back up do you take enough damage
but the motorcycle scene like that works
really well motorcycles are a great
vehicle to have a fight on but I mean we
can't forget about those lovely horses I
mean it's you know it's kind of the
old-school motorcycle fight what what
goes into a horse fight Scott from your
perspective on set I was I mean and the
funny thing with the horses are the dogs
you know you you can't even put the
animals at risk at all you know and
obviously you can't put your hero at
risk so just keeping that you got to
start with what can we do and keeping
them safe and the horse master Ted
Griffith and I spent a lot of time
developing
an ability a spotting rig basically to
book Keanu on but Keanu we could keep
safe but then how do you keep the horse
that is a free agent that if the horse
decides to wants to head left at any
point in time at a full gallop no you
had to be able to to corral that and
have you know keep him under control and
and you know Keanu trained I don't know
for months with horses so he I mean he
legitimately could ride and but when
you're riding and hanging on the side of
horse it takes years to learn that
so we had to be able to get him
comfortable enough on a horse to then
put him on the side of the horse you
know and you got to learn how to ride on
top of the horse before you learn how to
ride on the side of the horse yeah
grace oh okay I'll spot you the horse
fly it at the motorcycle fight the knife
fight is one of those fights your
favorite or is there another one in John
wick three that you said that's the one
there's another I really loved the fight
with the guys from the raid yah yah yah
yah duplex yeah and with the way the
night cut the glass that was like
amazing and how the assassins would I'd
you know it all black and the shadows
and turn around and be like whoohoo
surprise I don't know it's been tapped
and that was a really interesting fight
sequence too because they they survived
it and and so we'll get into this later
in the talk but it's like oh they they
live so what's gonna happen with that
but it's just great to see any time you
have the raid 2 and you have people who
are in those fight sequences in a movie
it's good news Alex yeah and like the
reason why that one works too is you
know when he leaves people alive at the
end it also informs the character like
oh wow John wick seems to respect people
and he doesn't kill them if it respects
them he wants to raid 30 obviously but
like and I run one force awakens cut was
coming out and you Jana and she chap and
Eko they were all sort of advertised
with being in force awakens you're like
cool and then you watch it and they get
eaten by like a space octopus in like
two minutes it's called a wrath are
right okay
yeah and so to see this movie yeah and
this is a first and foremost a martial
arts movie to see these two characters
just really spar with John wick it kind
of I think represents like the most fun
of martial arts is seeing these two
venerable the door these venerable
actors coming together and just
respectfully fighting it out yeah and
fun fact about our own Alex vote ladies
and gentlemen see you actually got to
see a super early screening oh yeah you
got to see it still when like wait they
were like stuntmen on wires yeah yeah so
like you mentioned the like the wire
harness you develop for Keanu so the cut
I saw you still sort of saw those wires
just kind of hanging on him in the and
in the beginning in the fight in the
library with the bulb and Mirjana vision
yes you can still see the prop knife
going into Keanu and even during that
scene you know it's funny there's no
music playing during the library fight
and I was like is the music not done or
is that the joke it's like it's like the
quiet fight you have it looks like the
quiet fight from the other guys you know
when there's like wrestling on the
ground during a funeral was amazing
especially in that scene like you heard
every bone break oh that was amazing
yeah the library fight to me that that's
all you be my favorite not just because
I'm a huge NBA fan so for Mom or
Jonathan she's having a tough week of
76ers lost two classes on a crazy quiet
job then he also gets killed by a book
that's got if he's dead is just jaw
might just be broke that's a great point
he's a big guy you can take a baby
pretty how do you come up with a book
fight first of all I don't execute no
again it's you know it's the miracle the
beauty of Chad and and Jonathan and John
Valera and the whole team they you know
they they spend this is what they do you
know they spend they're not gonna do
what's been done before just because
it's easy you know Chad you know you
talked about the sound design the Chad
goes to great lengths for that
no he goes to great lengths he he puts
his you know he touches everything you
know he's not you know he lives this you
know he's making a movie that he wants
to see he's a big fan boy of all the
martial arts movies and all these guys
and he the things that would piss him
off at other movies he's not going to be
it's not gonna happen in his movie yeah
and you can tell because he brings in
such all-stars to combat against John
wick one of whom is Mark Dacascos which
was exciting to me because I see the way
that he's like this this cool assassin
grace and I'm almost wondering if in the
future of John wick artistry can we have
them be like a kind of like for lack of
a better term the Bond girls where you
have this like guests are coming and be
an assassin that's cool you can kind of
vibe with that might be going against
John wick well Mark Dacascos was so
amazing because not only were his action
scenes fantastic but to make him like
this fanboy for John Weng like when he
sat down in the couch he could have said
anywhere in the continental it's right
next to Kyoto yeah and Mark played that
perfectly' it was just I love and his
cheekbones yes like his killer
cheekbones and you guys lit him so
beautifully I mean I was like maybe the
blade went between his lungs and he
could maybe get up later I like don't
want him to go away
yeah Alex it was fun watching him be be
a fan of John wick and I think it'd be
fun to have like just other assassins in
this world because we know how many
contracts are currently out right now so
there could be other assassins that come
in they're fans of John wick but also
maybe we as an audience can relate to
right
I would pick I don't pick Wesley Snipes
too because one like he already is a
black belt in karate and Hapkido I
believe and he's currently paying his
debt to society making a direct-to-dvd
action movie so I thought you're gonna
say because he's not in jail anymore
jail see he's the next Universal Soldier
cuz I felt this was like kill them on
the same level as that
should be great hey we got we got we got
Night Fights why not have sword fights
one of the great additions to John wick
3 in this universe was that of Halle
Berry she came in and we got so excited
as fans when we saw an image of her with
the two tournament Shepherds and we
actually see her get to work in this
movie Scott I mean she was such a force
to be reckoned with I think she really
added a lot to John wick 3 into the
storyline yeah I mean I heard Chad make
a quote that the best way to fake
something and to the best way to fake
being good is just be good and that's
what she you know I know I think I was
talking to Chad you know a little bit
before she was cast and I was like is
she in for this he goes oh yeah she's in
and you know she trained long and hard
I think it's noted that she even broke a
couple ribs and I mean she poured in she
wasn't I don't know if she took it
personally or what but she knew you know
what Keanu did and she wasn't going to
come in and do anything less
well now you watch her in this movie and
and I've seen a lot of fans online
talking about how they would love to
somehow like the Charlize Theron
character from atomic blonde I know
you've worked with Charlize do it have
her and Halle Berry maybe team up oh
okay you think she can hold her own
against Charlize Oh
I mean Sharlee the same work ethic you
know and same level of you know their
talent as act actresses or without
question yeah grace the end of this
movie clearly indicates that John wick
and the franchise ain't going anywhere
so would you be up for a Halle Berry
character spin-off eventually one day I
don't want to dilute the John wick magic
I maybe would like her to return and
John wick for it would be great
but there isn't a lot of talk these days
about like all-female team ups you have
the eighth floor situation and Avengers
end game so and they're you know
speaking of Charlize Theron they're
thinking of doing a spin-off from The
Fast and Furious with her character so
if they are gonna do an all-women
team-up I think Alan Berry's definitely
gonna be on that list for any of these
franchises yeah and Alex I mean Halle
Berry is great in the movie and it's so
awesome that she brings the dogs along
for the fun right the dogs
steal scenes in this film and they're
just so
to watch yeah and it's like a great
contrast or maybe companion to what you
know John wicks journey when the dogs
get shot and Casablanca
you know Halle Berry is about to go off
maybe nervous
John looks all like I get it yeah and it
suggests like you know these past three
weeks when John would have been pretty
shitty but he's learning he's like maybe
I should have reacted with the dogs in
that way so again like that moment
produced another character moment for
John wick but yeah the dogs are a
perfect complement perfect addition to
the series yeah definitely because the
movie like Charlie three addressed the
one thing I wanted the movie to do ask
John with two was that I felt like John
with two had a lot of head shots
not as much combat so in this one Keanu
John with Sprint's doing all
hand-to-hand combat allowing Halle Berry
to come up with her dogs to do all the
gunplay I think that was a perfect
choice you know we get that those nicely
low shots where you really get to see
everything play it off around yeah the
other thing I liked about the dogs was
that you know women just aren't as
strong as men and sometimes some movies
will try to pretend that you know that
they are so I like the big dogs and
Halle Berry's gunplay because I think
that it made it realistic that she was
able to level the playing field that way
by being a little smarter and coming up
with like these you know work arounds so
I thought that was really fantastic
I love the grace brings up workarounds
because Scott we were talking just
before we went to air about the dogs and
and how much of that was these actual
actor dogs versus CGI you showed Alex
and I click grace I'm so sorry we got to
send this to you after he's got a clip
on his phone of of the dogs actually
doing the wall climb and that's not a
faked thing that's like an actual dog
performing that stunt yeah I read in one
of you're one of the critics that didn't
give it a fresh complain about the CG
dog running up the wall and so I felt
the need to show you that it was a real
dog running up a real wall yeah and
that's the issue with having watching so
many movies that are just you know wall
to wall CG you
we believe when you see anymore but you
know reading interview no chest Alaska
he's all like we did shoot in a Sahara
you know we do go to Rome we go to all
we did shoot all motorcycles on the
bridge it's all real and we should
appreciate you know stuff like that when
we're seeing it practical in real time I
mean the movies based in reality
you know he's not doing these I mean you
know even even the fall at the end you
know like it is actually survivable
because really what we designed it would
knock the crap out of you but you know
as Jackson spinel showed us it's
survivable he did it yeah as we you know
people think that's CG and it's not it's
all real but you know we we built you
know we built it for him to be able to
do it yeah might not have might not have
killed him but you're definitely in
concussion protocol for a little bit
after a fall like that well our next
topic is going to be the world-building
that we got to see in John wig 3 because
so much of so much of the mythology got
expanded in this movie I mean you you
get to see the high order and you get to
see like the administration the
adjudicator so Alex I'm giving you all
these kind of things that we that we
built on from the first to John wick
movies which once stood out to you as
far as the war goes the one that stood
out was when he's being chased by Mark
Dacascos and he stops and he touches the
steps of the Continental and he's like
you can't hurt me anymore I'm like is
this freeze tag this was how the rules
work so I was actually not a huge fan of
how the Lord evolved it you know in the
first movie it's like tantalizing you're
like what is this world who are all
these people and part two you're like
wow this is expanding its across the
globe it involves everybody I feel in
part three it's getting just a little
creaky a little restricting so for as
much as I really enjoyed John III the
lower stuff I felt was sort of now
holding the series back a little bit a
grace do you agree with that point that
maybe we got a little too much into the
lore in the mythology and building this
world out a little too big no I
I liked it I thought for finally clicked
for me you know for the first two John
wicks I felt used it's kind of running
around which is fine with me
but I didn't really get a sense of the
world but here I have finally started to
see it all come together for me the the
tender worked the best you know the
ticket to see Angelica Houston the
marker with Halle Berry I know there was
a marker used in the second film but to
hear it really drove at home even the
dogs
I understood the dogs more finally that
they were you know the only sense of
pure heart loyalty these assassins could
could have in their lives so I thought
it was great yeah it's got so many times
in movies I feel like we try to get too
deep into a character's backstory when
we didn't really want to go there and
that was my nervousness when I saw that
we were gonna explore John Wick's past a
little bit but I actually found myself
really gravitating towards I think it's
really cool he was he was trained in
ballet and we get to know what his
backstory is this is a fan of the
franchise that pay off for you yeah I
mean I when I read it in the script I
loved it because it it didn't give you
so much that you're like it it it left
enough that you didn't understand to
where he still had these all these
abilities you know to explore where
you're like you shouldn't be able to do
that but it showed you enough to really
go that makes sense you know and it was
and it's subtle like you know what no
not everything in John works obviously
subtle but it was just him walking
through and you see some people doing
ballet and you see some guys throwing
each other on their head and you know
you're like oh I get it
and then they move on yeah and you know
what we knew that there were that there
were other Continentals and then seeing
the seeing Morocco seeing casablanca
seeing that kind of thing i like the way
that they built upon that i understand
your point alex where it's like okay
we're we're stressing us a little thin
but i want more of these and i like that
we can now make this an international
kind of thing and not just a a domestic
right field yeah i want to see all the
hotels i would see all of them what else
was cool is that we're really getting
nods to not only cinema history but
Keanu Reaves history with this movie
because there's a lot of references to
the matrix here and I think maybe
whereas with the first John wick movie
where you didn't want to harken back to
your past you and establish yourself as
your own franchise
we had a
a lot of references to the matrix one of
the more on the nose ones was that we
actually get to see the doctor
it's it Randall duck Kim who obviously a
key master from the matrix and then we
also got this really sweet underwater
fight with the slow-motion bullets it's
got onset is are we talking about the
matrix are we saying hey this is kind of
like when neo had to dodge bullets no
that just me as a fan embrace did you
read as far into that as I did the
connection with the bullets underwater
but I liked it a lot
I think that's really good I think I
think it works because this was born out
of the matrix I mean that's where you
know Chad and Keanu forged their
friendship that led to this so I think I
think it's an appropriate not I think
it's safe to say you know that's why you
see so many character actors from the
matrix because that was such a you know
as a you know professional that works in
the industry
not every movie is the same and not it
some were easier or some are harder or
some you've you form these friendships
in these real last lasting relationships
and obviously you see all I mean Chad's
worked on honey you know 150 movies you
don't see people from all those other
movies you're seeing so it said sort of
a testimony to the matrix and what those
people all went through together yeah as
people outside of you know making a
movie yeah and I think the way you know
people keep on bringing up the matrix
it's done out of like admiration yeah
spec for the movie and you know John
would in no way lives in the shadow of
the matrix but I think as viewer that
audiences we love to see that sort of
flow that connection from the matrix all
the way into John wick yeah yeah I was I
was I was connecting a lot of dots
during the lobby fight to because you
got the green light it's kind of
matrixes nevertheless we move on to the
very tantalizingly abrupt ending that we
got with John wick 3 which as a fan of
the franchise I'm kind of excited about
because it means we're probably getting
John wick for so grace what are some of
the things that you're excited about
seeing possibly in John wick for I think
guest stars as you pointed
out I think you know I want to say that
you know continuing to bring you know
people in I think is the movies get
better you can get even better people to
come in like you know you can get it
open Thurman you can get it was like
Snipes also I just want to see how they
can possibly top themselves I agree with
all of you that while I was watching the
movie I was like well how much longer
can you go on like this and they're like
for the entire movie and it was shocking
yeah I got asked you scouted me does the
prospect of a fourth John wick movie
does it make you excited as it thank you
exhausted oh it's great I mean
especially when you're creating
something that's not been done before
you know as a creative person you know
like like Chad doesn't want to go just
do another fight
he wants to do the knife fight he wants
to do a frightened horse you know horse
food and car foo and you know so the the
opportunity to or even you know the
motorcycle from villainous to take that
and like okay this has been done but we
can't do that we got to do it like this
so that's I mean that's what why I even
do what I do
ultimately yeah Alex we thought we got a
cool buzzword out of the first John wick
with gun food now we get horse foo and
caribou and motor cycle foo I guess I'll
tell what I really want to see in John
look for is I want to see because
there's so many foods in the world we're
it's gonna be food fights it's gonna be
great fighters the david girl can do the
soundtrack for the fourth one it's gonna
be this whole melting pot what i want to
see is i because we we mentioned John
wick has some sort of code and he's even
left some assassins that were going
after him alive so Alex do you think we
could see a assassins assembled kind of
moment where it's actually John wick
teaming up with other assassins
ultimately I think so yeah I mean the
way the way we could talk about like did
Ruby Rose or heirs die in John Luke
chapter two you know or common with the
right did he get to the hospital or not
you know yeah but you know what they're
gonna have to start doing is introducing
characters who actually live you know
Mark Dacascos as awesome as he was as
zero well I think he dies we appreciate
dies on this one yeah right
he'll walk around with a sword on the
whole movie in part for
you know but yeah like this from what we
see with you know part 2 and part 3 this
series can go anywhere it could kind of
withstand any kind of thing you throw at
it so yeah like bring on the assassins
assemble yeah the actual franchise can
go on anywhere we could get John wick
four or five six seven and we'd probably
line up to see all of them there's also
the recent announcement that there's
going to be a spin-off show on Starz
about the Continental so Alex do you
have any sort of timeline where that
maybe should take place should that be a
prequel to John wick what are you
thinking I think you know I have
honestly almost no interest in watching
a TV show about the Continental so if I
were to get me hooked on it I would
probably go like maybe a prequel maybe
the building of the Continental I would
I would watch maybe like a Downton Abbey
or like Gosford Park style where it's
just about the people who got the yeah
work day-to-day the Continental the ones
with like the bellhops yeah alright and
like if you can make a continental TV
show with no violence then I'll watch it
yeah grace did Alex just sell you on a
star subscription production values but
if you can do the bellhop like I love
that in this movie the concierge stepped
out from behind his desk you know I'd
love to see what like what are the
protocols you know what are the
trainings we know what are the rules for
the staff that would be really cool or
even the women who are running the the
the phone booths or don't the phone line
yeah like day to day yeah yeah but we
also want to you know it keeps Skye
gainfully employed so I'd like to see
some exactly well we may not get a whole
lot of stunt work in this continental
show at least the version that Alex and
grace are pitching but what has been the
talk of the town recently is whether the
Academy Awards could open up a category
for best stunt work in a movie it's one
of the most debated topics when you
think about the Oscars in the last few
years so Scott I want to ask you do you
think that John wick 3 might be the
movie that could finally be that
watershed moment where the Academy
recognizes stunts and presents the
stunts of the year with an Oscar I is is
it worthy of that yes absolutely
I mean stunts is the only on-camera
craft that's not recognized by the
Oscars
will they I don't think so grace do you
share Scott's pessimism or do you think
that we are in the running to have stunt
work rewarded at the Academy Awards well
this year it might be too hard to get
something a category approved that
quickly but you might maybe get like an
honorary Oscar that would be something
nice but I think that it's occurring to
a number of people watching this that
the artistry is so strong that it is
worthy of that recognition and I think
that the really important distinction is
that I think in the past people have
been reluctant cuz they think it's just
the stuff they're thinking of rewarding
the stunt performer and that's difficult
because it's a shared performance with
the actor obviously the actors are very
territorial as to who has ownership of
the role but when you think about
someone like Scott like the stunt
choreographer and you see how important
that is that's where the Oscar I think
should go you should go to the you know
the coordinator and the whole department
yeah it's kind of a loaded question to
ask you Scott do you think the
coordinator should get because I think
I'm the best we want to give you that
trophy so very bad Alec can you do
reward the group to reward the performer
how would you do it if you are in charge
of the Oscars I think it would have to
be you know kind of like when you give a
movie Best Picture it goes not to the
director to produce her so I think kind
of like the person who oversees the
whole thing like I would be into it if
it was called achievement and popular
film where you know if that was the a
was a category that the Academy sort of
introduced in and you know that kind of
imploded I I think that's what they were
trying to kind of go like you know we
don't have a category for stunts but we
love the stunt work in John Wayne three
I think that's where they were probably
wanted to put that so instead of like
you we have honorary Oscar so like Total
Recall for the 40 effects they got one
for Toy Story you know so instead
instead of like doing this like you know
individual honorary once it's like put
all like the cool stuff like you know
maybe black panther head like
best don't work as well put that popular
film that's gonna confuse VFX with
stunts you know like I think last year
the clear one a winner would have been
Mission Impossible fall out and I think
if you have a just popular category I
mean forget the problem was saying what
is the best picture the best unpopular
felt you know I think that Avengers end
game is like going to be considered like
the fan favorite of the big blockbuster
and I think that it wouldn't highlight
the artistry of John wick cos as you
pointed out and that's all real that's
wire work that's a VFX well let's change
to when you know effects has been
there's been a category for effects for
a long time but if you look back 20
years ago it was to mechanical effects
guys than 1 the effects guy every now
and again now it's all the effects guys
and one mechanical effects guy but
they're all under the effects even
though visual effects and mechanical
effects are pretty different I mean even
the fact we're having any sort of
conversation about the Oscars
surrounding John wick 3 means that we
really approve of this movie and like I
said at the top it's it's fresh right
now 95 percent the first two are
certified fresh 87 89 percent
respectively so I mentioned at the top
and now I ask the ultimate question of
my panelists grace I'm gonna start with
you is John wick the best action
franchise in history I think when you
put it like that this this the latest
installment gets it there just because
of how it's coordinated it's almost like
a symphony it's just so perfectly done
and oh the action sequences are thought
about every level from sound visuals to
lighting to the actual fights to the
acting it's it's beautiful so it might
be and the level of artistry is great
pointed out it's just it's you y'all
have kept topping yourselves with these
John wicks it's got are you are you able
to separate yourself from from the work
and say no I think that John wick might
be in the running for best action
franchise of all time yeah I mean
without question I think what ultimately
gives it that distinction is that it
each one steps up it's you know we know
how many trilogy is out there sort of
fall off you know by the time you get to
the third one it's sort of stale and
like
whatever and John wick obviously doesn't
do that so the fact that it steps up the
third one being the best of the three
and in my opinion I think you agree
gives it that distinction yeah I think
Alex I mean I'm wrestling with the fact
that we've been blessed with so many
Mission Impossible movies I still just
for a nostalgic purposes and because I
love the first three so much I'm gonna
throw diehard into the mix you had a
clear-cut action franchise that lifts
itself above the rest I think John wick
is probably at the top because do
Mission Impossible took a moment to
become an action franchise I started as
a spy thriller franchise you had like
Indiana Jones but that guy kind of got
solid with the Crystal Skull and but
yeah I mean the fact that John wick came
out of the gate this good and keeps on
getting better probably puts it at the
top maybe tying it was like the police
story series please story I wanted to
and super cop I'd like to think a really
important element is that it's made by
guys with a stunt background you know it
was born out of the stunt you know the
relationship between two Keano and Chad
you know the stunt you know you and your
team Scott are working so actively as a
part of it and I think that's also
really important that's a great point
Grayson I'm glad you said it was born
out of that because it reminded me of
the Jason Bourne movie so I would throw
that in there as well so the debate will
continue to rage on as to whether John
wick is the best action franchise in
history but we can at least say this
after John wick three we're all very
excited about more adventures into John
wick universe I am so happy to be joined
by a great panel day I want to thank
Alex grace and Scott for hanging out
with me talking John wick three and
thank you guys for watching today's
episode make sure you comment let us
know your thoughts on John wick three
what was your favorite fight sequence
what do you want to see out of John wick
for what was your favorite part of the
war the myth building we want to hear
from you and make sure you click that
bell right there because that's going to
give you an alert the next time in after
show drops anytime a big movie comes out
that Saturday we're gonna have one of
these for you for my entire panel and
everybody here at Rotten Tomatoes I'm
Mark Ellis and we'll see you real soon
[Music]
you
[Music]